you are watching cold feet in TV
hey welcome to another episode of
ColdFusion TV - gogo here our modern
world is increasingly shaped by the
technology we use each and every day it
can make our lives easier provide
enjoyment entertainment or vast amounts
of information over the years there have
been a few key mobile devices that would
pave the way for things to come
sometimes it's pretty interesting to
take a look back at the precursors to
our modern mobile way of life let's
start with something from way back
number 10 but this is their portable
game system it's called the Game Boy and
unlike older handheld games they aren't
limited to one single game the Nintendo
Game Boy from 1989 if you're over the
age of 21 there's a pretty high chance
that you would have enjoyed a feast
Nicci games on the original Game Boy or
its younger brother The Game Boy Color
for a while there were all the rage and
it seemed that addictive simple games
and portability with a perfect
combination for the day for those of you
that aren't old enough to really grasp
what a portable device from Nintendo
really meant here's a small news report
from 91 let's just say that video games
that had the Nintendo brand were huge
our video game industry is hotter than
ever this season and one good reasons
Nintendo was introduced from hotland
toys but have things gone a bit too far
so it has come to this therapy sessions
for families whom you could call
Nintendo or saw the peer pressure star
like you maybe exploit it
psychologists offices might get more
crowded this holiday season at $200 a
Super Nintendo setup cost twice as much
as the old system and you can't mix and
match some parents are refusing to be
taken in I'm going to say no and I'm
going to explain to him how people
market things to make you spend more
money but no matter how you play the
game or which game you play things
definitely have come a long way since
pac-man number 9 the Texas Instruments
SR 10 from 1973 1973 it was a time when
computers were nowhere to be found in
the classroom there was all slide rules
and physical forms of counting then came
the Texas Instruments SR 10 it really
revolutionized the education system for
the maths and Sciences anyway for 150
dollars you can calculate all the
reciprocals square roots and slide rule
functions you wanted I guess it would
have been a nerds paradise but it would
have made things a whole lot easier
though number 8 the first Walkman by
Sony in 1979 this was portable music not
a radio but real portable music any song
you wanted in your pocket basically
science fiction at the time a personal
soundtrack to your life for as long as
the tape lasted anyway when the Walkman
debuted in 1979 no one had ever seen
anything quite like it people would have
been asking themselves why is that guy
wearing headphones in the middle of the
street the Sony Walkman virtually
invented the concept of personal
electronics the Walkman was actually
branded as the stowaway sound about and
the free style until Sony finally stuck
with the name Walker the first few units
featured two sets of headphone jacks so
you could share music with a friend and
be social with your technology the
Walkman sold over 330 million units in
its lifetime
number seven the Apple iPod from 2001
the iPod single-handedly saved apple
from the grave in 2000 it was said that
some of Apple's board members were
planning to sell the company but fast
forward five years and by 2005 eight out
of every ten portal players sold in
retail where iPods the first iPod costs
$400 and had a 5 gigabyte hard drive the
thing was it was only compatible with
Macs from the second generation onwards
windows compatibility came into the
picture and literally the Scylla slimmin
white headphones with a symbol of the
2000s number 6 this next one isn't one
device but a series of devices and you
can probably guess which series yep it's
the Galaxy Note series coming in at
number 6 in 2011 even though the Dell
Streak came before it it was the note
series that spawned the tablet phone
trend and drove the screen size of
virtually every device upwards companies
could now think well Samsung's got a 5.7
inch device selling like hotcakes
so an extra point five inches of screen
real estate nail device couldn't hurt it
made people realize that phones could be
actually a lot more than commonly
thought of course the note series wasn't
perfect but it spoke hints of things to
come number five the Motorola StarTAC
from 1996 before the StarTAC mobile
phones were literally bricks Motorola
shocked people with this incredibly
small device with a unique design yes it
was the very first clamshell phone a
form factor that would set the design
standard for mobile phones for years to
come but that wasn't all this phone
pioneered the vibrating ring the StarTAC
helped drive mobile phones into the
mainstream selling around 60 million
units in its lifetime number four looks
like 1996 was a big year for technology
because coming in at number four is the
mighty Palm Pilot from 1996 of course
this is where the PDA went mainstream of
course there was actually Apple that
beat palm to the punch a few years
earlier with the Newton but really the
Newton wasn't designed well and had poor
handwriting recognition which was
supposed to be its main selling point on
the other hand the pine pilot gave
professionals freedom from their pcs for
the very first time with syncable
address books
date book
a memo pad and much more number three
the IBM Simon from 1994 now this was
pretty much the first smartphone ever
conceived it had everything to make it a
smartphone but way before its time it
had a 4.5 inch touchscreen with no
buttons it could send and receive faxes
and emails had an address book a
calendar an appointment scheduler a
calculator a world time clock and
electronic notepad handwritten
annotations and much more and this was
20 years ago the IBM Simon was literally
just too advanced for his time and
people back then didn't have a clue what
they're looking at but of course the IBM
Simon's legacy would be picked up many
years later number 2 the Motorola
DynaTAC 8000x from 1983 and if you don't
know this was the very first mobile
phone the one that started it all and
who better to explain it to us than the
guy that invented it mr. Martin Cooper
he is an interview with the first phone
literally caught what would today be a
million dollars we have to virtually
shut down all engineering at our company
and have her everybody working on the
phone and the infrastructure to make the
phone work even in 1983 a portable
handheld cellular telephone not unlike
this one cost $4,000 $4,000 which would
be the equivalent of more than $10,000
today the team that actually put the
parts together in this did an
extraordinary job but they have to
squeeze many may thousands of parts into
this phone the industrial designers also
did a superb job but their design was
this big and and it was shaped like this
but by the time the engineers got done
we ended up with two and a half pounds
over two kilos a very substantial part
of that first phone was in fact battery
and even then we had a battery that
weighed four or five times more than an
entire cell phone does today and even
then the
battery life time was 20 minutes but
that wasn't really a big problem because
you couldn't hold that phone up for 20
minutes I hope you enjoyed the video so
far but before we get to number one
let's just take a quick break and then
I'll be back straight after this America
Online introduces new version 4.0 there
has never been a better time to get
online everyone I know is on it we've
spent over 1 billion dollars to create a
state-of-the-art high-speed network and
with 56 K connections are faster than
ever it's the ultimate local guide near
4.0 check it out
it's my connection to the world America
Online number one an iPod a phone and an
Internet communicator an iPod a phone
are you getting it
these are not three separate devices
this is one device
and we are calling it iPhone
today
today Apple is going to reinvent the
phone what else can I say this was the
device that changed how we think about
the mobile phone the phone was no longer
something you just made calls with and
did organizational tasks with now the
phone could be basically anything that
you imagined the key was the screen
technology and the App Store most
touchscreen phones around the 2007
period were using resistive touchscreen
technology which was slow clunky and
just hard to use Steve Jobs was adamant
to cram capacitive touchscreen
technology into his device no matter how
hard it was going to be capacitive
touchscreen technology is incredibly
accurate slick and it allowed for easy
multi-touch gestures and it proved to be
the way forward and sure the iPhone was
locked down and closed off but there's
no denying that this device paved the
way forward but I can't leave it there
because there is a little bit of
controversy between the LG Prada and the
iPhone as the LG Prada went on sale one
month before the iPhone and had a
similar overall concept but as history
tells us the iPhone proved to be much
more influential so there you have it
the top 10 most influential devices of
our time without some of these devices
our modern society could have been quite
a bit different today thanks for
watching and don't forget to give it a
thumbs up comment and subscribe if you
enjoyed it if you want to see more
alternative tech stuff like this my
channel is bursting with this so take a
look around and enjoy anyway you guys
have a good one and on cash again soon
for the next video cheers guys
how shootin
it's me thinking
you